i want to make sure we we have a little
bit of good news here we uh you know not
always just complaining but we have this
story from the daily mail former
mcdonald's ceo who invented the mcnugget
oh good for him sets up new group to
fight back against woke corporations and
buys enough bank of america shares to
formally propose that firm scraps staff
crt training whoa
ed rensey who served as the ceo of
mcdonald's in the 1990s is partnering
with conservative groups to fight back
against corporations he formed the
boardroom
emit imitative a partnership between the
job creators network the free enterprise
group and second vote the goal of the
group is to protect shareholders and
employers of publicly traded companies
from woke policies and ensure corporate
accountability it comes as left-wing
groups continue to buy up stocks and
businesses until they raise enough clout
to lobby the board to adopt leftist
policies companies are also being forced
to the left so they can receive high esg
score
which would make them more profitable
i would argue this environmental social
governance thing they're doing
via is these companies that embrace this
violate their fiduciary duty to the
shareholders and the shareholders need
to start filing lawsuits and on that on
those grounds
well you know companies that do that uh
should be subject to scrutiny by the
feds and uh state authorities because
you know in some states
and and generally speaking the law is
when you're charged with investing
someone's pension money you're supposed
to be trying to maximize the return and
that's your priority
using it for other purposes
to end the oil industry or advance
social agendas is
contrary to law
so it's not even a question of lawsuits
it's a question of are we going to have
law enforcement pursue these companies
and you've got these big companies like
blackrock
vanguard that are pushing this and
what's interesting is they push it here
but they're all they all own shares of
companies abroad they don't go they
don't go tell china companies chinese
companies you need to follow our our
woke agenda they tell american companies
so i think the concern conservatives
have to understand that corporations are
largely controlled by the left
uh and they're misusing and abusing our
funds and it's not a question of a
political difference it's a question of
misconduct
by the investors and as you point out
the corporations uh that are misusing
dollars and misusing our retirement
dollars
misusing shareholder dollars and
misusing our retirement dollars
to advance a political agenda that goes
that goes that's why florida is pulling
back disney's tax benefits because
they're misusing
the the the the uh trust that the public
has given them through these taxes
conservatives are getting aided now in
the culture war by post liberals people
who were very much involved in culture
and um arts
but because the woke left has gone so
insane because they seem to have no
principles you have people probably like
us who all of a sudden are just
rejecting and opposing this one of the
challenges we face in all of this is
there are still people who don't realize
the shift and what has happened so you
still hear these old talking points
about republicans or pro-corporation
it's like haven't you been around for
the past five years where the
conservatives were saying regulate big
tech because of censorship yeah times
have changed donald trump brought a lot
of people into the republican party who
are not traditional
or conservative in that capacity
and now
we need to find a way to get you know
people on the right who are still very
much like go to want to regulate
corporations and we got to get people on
the left to realize they're being
screwed over by the corporations then we
can make those changes well it's not
regulation to enforce the laws against
fraud or against the misuse of dollar i
mean we're not asking for more i don't
want more regulation of twitter i just
want them to be held accountable for
lying to regulators and shareholders and
users in congress about the purpose and
the process of their censorship saying
goes for facebook and google and youtube
they're lying when they're saying
they're applying neutral principles and
there's an algorithm that can't be
messed with and don't worry it's equally
applied it's a big lie and if and and it
should be investigated as such the way
that the oil companies were being
investigated for quote lying about
climate change which was bunk but they
they we've got to enforce the law
against these companies if elon musk
gets a hold of twitter and that appears
to be the news right now that he's going
to be raising some money and making a
move within like the next week or so
he's going to get all those documents
well he doesn't need the weight to get
control he's as a shareholder he can ask
for documents about the processes that
i'm talking about how is it the decision
was made to throw off trump you know i
was blocked for a tweet i made about
hydroxychloroquine that was completely
accurate twitter had found it to be
accurate they someone complained about
it they said it's a violation of the
rules three four months later they
locked me out of my account for posting
the same darn tweet
i mean they're lying when they're saying
they're doing things neutrally you know
in a way that could survive scrutiny if
they would survive scrutiny we should
rely on elon musk to get the documents
out i think that's an opportunity for
him to demand those documents as a
shareholder well to me that if we want
to go legally after these just
corporations in general for abusing
their shareholder trust that it would
have to be a decentralized move of law
fair so because if one unit like if you
were the only one to go then you're like
not a target like like they did when the
fbi goes into james o'keefe's house like
because he's because he's the head of
project veritas duh so like we need
everyone to go after it together and
maybe not that's obviously hyperbole but
we need enough people pushing against
these corporations for their fraud
narrative if there is such
that
it's it's i mean this that's what the
the spirit of the united states is
decentralized movement yeah we're we're
in a great suppression i call it the
great suppression i mean where thought
is being suppressed uh we have the biden
administration calling in big tech
companies to encourage them to censor
people that's right the big tech
companies are doing it i know judicial
watch uncovered that they were taking
material down at the behest of
government agencies our material other
material
so i mean the idea that this is some
sort of private actor out there no it's
part of a it's collusion
and uh
it's a crisis in the sense that you know
we're in this revolutionary period
they want to suppress our speech
and yes they want to jail us as as james
o'keefe has found as those being
targeted by the january 6th committee
are fight is fine i mean that they're
now
taking the position that if you were on
an alternative slate of electors in a
disputed election you're being
investigated by the justice department
they want to jail their political
opponents this is a revolutionary period
and our republic is tottering our
republic is soldering absolutely agreed
i wanted to ask you something about
the instance you brought up with the
white house actually instructing social
media companies to censor certain things
my understanding based on hearing that
is it sounds like a blatant first
amendment violation but i'm curious if
there's some kind of legal loophole
they're exploiting in order to get away
with this
well you know there's always legal
loopholes the question is are you going
to have
individuals and positions the power to
do something about it actually exercise
all their prerogatives
so for instance president trump was
impeached for no good reason yeah there
are plenty good reasons to impeach biden
and i'm not seeing republican leadership
talking about that in any significant
way the justice department's controlled
by joe biden
the opportunities it seems to me in
terms of enforcement against these
companies is at the state level and you
know ron desantis is taking some
leadership roles there there are some
more aggressive attorney generals
at the state level as well who
understand going after twitter in texas
demanding documents during a big
document fight with twitter about their
censorship policies
but it's got to be coordinated i mean
they're attacking our freedoms and our
civil rights and our civil liberties and
you know these are god-given these are
god-given civil liberties our right to
express our self is is god-given it's
not it's recognized by the constitution
but the right exists separate and apart
from it and everyone's coming after it
you said joe biden is in control of the
justice department do you mean by
appointing judges
constitutionally speaking he's
controlled the justice department is his
appointees uh the justice department is
run by the left it's a democratic
agency most of the agencies are
controlled by democrats and leftists and
the justice department is a locust of
evil when it comes to public policy in
our country every bad thing the
government does the justice department
defends it and or participates in it but
it's supposed to be a neutral entity
it's supposed to be an entity that
reflects the will of the people through
its appointed representative or elected
representative such as the president and
he has the justice department uh is run
by his attorney general and other senior
appointees or confirmed by the senate so
there are those checks in place
but the agency tends to do what it wants
to do and if there's a democrat in
office
uh they're free and clear and if they're
a republican in office
they're still free and yeah they used to
be at each other like john adams and
thomas jefferson man they would just
argue they'd get up there and think i'm
your vice president because i don't
agree with you and we're not going to
screw this up no it's not a cult so i'd
like to ask you
what's our way out of this
well you know i i always tell people you
know all you can do is what you can do
are you doing what you can do are we
using all the tools available to us
under the constitution our system of
government to
enforce the rule of law and protect our
rights and liberties are we doing what
we can do at the state level are you
active individually with your party if
these issues concern you are you
communicating with your elected
officials and your friends and your
colleagues
are you running for office or you're
participating in the party mechanics you
can complain about the republican party
but if you're not participating some
loser is probably participating who's in
it for all the wrong reasons and then
once they're elected we need men and
women of ambition who understand their
role in history
and
to protect our republic and to say we're
not turning over
the reins of our government to unelected
bureaucracies
we're not going to play this game where
we sign a check once a year for four
trillion dollars
and then see what happens and then
complain about it after the fact it's
like you know the government you know
congress is like uh the guy who says you
know the firefighters who set a fire
and then show up after the house burns
down and starts complaining well this is
terrible thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you